the afternoon we have your exams for you
you can get them after was that a sigh
of something was the average 76 and
based on the results we've decided to
make the final not cumulative but just
from now on okay yeah it was my idea
Saul didn't want to do it just kidding
we agreed all right so everybody got
that including you people not not here
in class this final will not be
cumulative it'll just be from the
lecture after the midterm okay today we
are going to talk about a particular
virus which is unusual for this course
we usually don't have lectures on
individual viruses in fact I designed
this course on purpose not to do that
rather to do it in terms of function in
steps of replication but this is a
really important virus this is the
pandemic of our era so it really
deserves a lecture of its own and that's
of course H HIV and the AIDS pandemic
and this story began in 1981 this is
actually a reproduction of the original
morbidity and mortality weekly report
publication of the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention and here is the
the beginning of that article in the
period October 1980 to May 1981 five
young men all active homosexuals were
treated for biopsy confirmed
Pneumocystis Carini pneumonia at three
different hospitals in LA two of the
patients died all five patients had
laboratory confirmed previous or current
CMV infection and candida mucosal
infection so this was the first report
of this unusual cluster of opportunistic
infections and it was followed by many
more
and I remember very vividly coming to
Colombia in 1982 and sitting down with
colleagues and they're saying have you
heard about this new infection no one
knows what it is well shortly afterward
it was sorted out and it's turned out
that this infection was caused by a new
retrovirus human immunodeficiency virus
that wasn't the name originally given to
it it was given two different names and
eventually at some point the
nomenclature committees got together and
came up with this so the virus was first
isolated in 1983 from the lymph node of
a patient with lymph adenopathy swollen
lymph nodes and this is one of the
typical presentations of this infection
this happened in Paris it was
subsequently isolated at the NIH and
UCSF a lot of controversy about who
discovered this initially books have
been written about it but it it's
clearly first isolated in Paris electron
microscopy of the virus and sequence
analysis showed that there are Lenti
viruses which was at this time already a
known group in the retrovirus family
which we'll talk about in a moment so
here is a cartoon of the virion
it's a typical retrovirus has an
envelope there are glycoproteins in the
envelope and within it is a core with a
variety of proteins reverse
transcriptase integrase RNA CH protease
and the viral RNA of which there are two
copies and here's an electron micrograph
so this has an unusual conical shaped
core this is characteristic of the
Lente's and this distinguishes it from
some of the other retroviruses as well
so the retrovirus family we've talked
quite a bit about retroviruses in terms
of replication but not so much about
disease it is divided into a couple of
sections if you will there are ortho
retro véronique there's another section
which I haven't shown here and this is
further divided into alpha retroviruses
beta gamma and Delta retroviruses and
epsilon and then finally lentiviruses
so the known human retrovirus
are either Delta retroviruses htlv 1 2 &
3 human t-cell leukemia viruses these
are actually discovered before HIV and
then HIV 1 and to these htlv s by the
way in fact many millions of people
worldwide as well 10 to 15 million the
most part these infections do not cause
disease but there are rare cases of T
cell leukemia x' and other inflammatory
diseases as well so today we'll talk
about HIV one largely HIV 2 was
discovered subsequently and these are
lentiviruses that's what I mean when we
call them Len T's that's the way they're
classified here's a nice schematic of
the virus particle this is from a very
nice Swiss web site called viral zone
they make nice pictures of viruses so
you can see again the conical shaped
core which contains the 2 copies of RNA
reverse transcriptase integrase this is
embedded within a veer an envelope very
on the envelopes on the outside there is
a protein a matrix protein that gives
the envelope some support and you notice
here there are only a few glycoproteins
drawn and this is accurate these very
odds don't have a lot of glycoproteins
embedded in them some of the other
envelope viruses we've talked about I
show you pictures and the outside the
envelope is packed with glycoproteins
that's not the case with HIV variants
now the genome as you know is a plus
strand RNA and it encodes a number of
proteins which are shown here from our
previous discussions of retroviruses you
may remember that they encode the gag
protein which is a structural precursor
it gives rise to all the proteins that
are in the virion the capsid for example
the nucleo capsid protein which binds to
the RNA so forth reverse transcriptase
is encoded in the pawl region and then
we have the envelope glycoprotein of
course which is studded Stud which is
embedded in the membrane of the virus
this these viruses have an addition many
other proteins they're called accessory
proteins and you see some of them
written here viv tat and fuel grab for
example and they have a variety of
functions that have been sorted out over
the years one of them is VP u right here
it's very faint and we'll talk a little
bit about that later these all have very
specific functions it's not found in all
retroviruses so for that reason we call
these complex retroviruses there are two
distinct groups of human retroviruses we
have the leukemia viruses htlv 1 2 3 & 4
and the immunodeficiency viruses which
we'll talk about today hiv-1 and hiv-2
again these are lentiviruses
when these were discovered lentiviruses
were not new they were already a number
of lentiviruses of other animals already
known for example equine infectious
anemia virus which causes an
immunodeficiency of horses and this was
isolated in the early 1900s so the idea
of an immunodeficiency causing virus
wasn't new it had been seen already in
other animals so the name of course is
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome and
the syndrome which we've used quite a
few times already in this course is the
occurrence together of a characteristic
group or pattern of symptoms now usually
when you say when you call something a
syndrome is it's because you don't know
what causes it in part and here we now
know the cause but syndrome has stuck
with the name but there are other
afflictions that still use syndrome in
the name because we don't know what
causes them HIV 1 is the etiological
agent of AIDS there is no question about
this if you search the literature you
will find many people who believe that
HIV does not cause AIDS and this is
completely wrong
this is pseudoscience wrong stuff it's
just nonsense it's a waste of time to
read it or to even think about it
so this hypothesis has been very well
demonstrated in a variety of ways and
one of them is the inadvertent infection
of people with HIV contaminated blood
and the very beginning of the epidemic
people at working in health care
institutions would stick themselves
or transfusions would be given without
knowing that there is HIV in the blood
and these people were infected so it's a
it's a good fulfillment shouldn't say
good it is a fulfillment of Koch's
postulates you put the organism back in
the host and show that it causes the
original disease so HIV causes AIDS
don't believe anyone who tells you
otherwise in fact there's some very
there's some very respectable
virologists who continue to say that HIV
does not cause AIDS but they're from
California and the u.s. HIV s killed
over half a million people which exceeds
all the combat related deaths in all the
wars fought in the twentieth century
over a million people in the u.s. are
infected about a quarter of them don't
even know it
they haven't been diagnosed there are
40,000 new infections every year in the
u.s. 70% men 30% women need to give you
a lot of statistics I don't expect you
to know these statistics I'm just trying
to impress on you the extent of this
problem half of all new infections in
the US occur in people 25 years of age
or younger so here are some graphs to
give you an idea of the pattern of AIDS
in the u.s. starting from the 90s here
up till 2007 last year a very
comprehensive report was published by UN
AIDS which has all of these statistics
in it this is the estimated adult HIV
prevalence ages 15 to 49 this has been
rather steady over the last years it was
initially on the increase since 1990 but
it's steady these are three different
estimates this is a high estimate a low
estimate and and in the middle the
number of people living with HIV has
steadily increased over the years and
the number of AIDS death peaked around
1995 has gone down and depending on
which curve you look at it's either
rising again a remaining constant at
20,000 a year in the US and the global
picture is shown here these are the
number of individuals with HIV infection
in each in each continent and then below
it is the range
so we don't have terribly precise
numbers as you can see from the range
North America 1.3 million you can see
the greatest burden is sub-saharan
Africa 22 and a half million is probably
higher because this was a couple of
years old already so globally there are
many many people infected 33.2 global
infections number of people living with
HIV in 2008 now here are some numbers
what's really disturbing is that
children under 15 years there quite a
few of those here 2.1 million people
newly infected in 2008 there are a
million the millions for adults and four
hundred thirty thousand for children
under 15 years and then AIDS related
deaths in 2008 these are global numbers
again two million total of which 280,000
are our children now if you wonder how
this fits into the pattern of diseases
and infections in general I show you
this slide which is more bit tality and
morbidity due to selected infectious
diseases and so here's the annual number
of deaths so we'll look at this in the
different infections so lower
respiratory tract infections are the
biggest killers and this includes
bacterial and viral infections diarrheal
diseases remember Victoria Falls 2.1
million right this well from losing
water for the most part hiv/aids so is
number 3 2 million deaths morbidity and
mortality a year followed by
tuberculosis malaria meas a look at
measles well up there with these
diseases neglected diseases and even
polio is still quite high up here so
just to give you a perspective of what's
going on globally there's still quite a
bit of work to do
now as for as far as controlling age
goes we will talk about this a lot more
when we talk about antivirals and
vaccines but I just want to mention that
triple drug therapy has slowed the
pandemic that is using three drugs that
wants to get around the problem of
resistance and we'll talk about the
numbers later in
their lecture but this is only good in
countries with money because these are
very expensive so unfortunately poor
countries though aren't able to use
these triple drug therapies so in poor
countries people continue to die because
they can't access antivirals Bill Gates
could probably help out here these are
some of the antiretroviral agents that
have been approved in the US the pathway
of AIDS antiviral discovery has been
phenomenal from the onset there's been
an amazing amount of research going into
this and you can see there over 20
different drugs of all sorts and we'll
go into these in another lecture in more
detail these were initially used
individually but they rapidly selected
for viral mutants that were resistant
and then the idea came to do them in
combination so now we have fixed dose
combination of three they're currently
six different combinations of three
different drugs that are approved for
use in the US and in particular this
this pill called a triplet it's one pill
that has all three in it it makes it
very easy to take these drugs as opposed
to taking three separate ones so this is
called heart or highly active
antiretroviral therapy or combination
therapy so this can really extend the
life span of individuals that have are
infected with HIV one but the problem is
there's no cure we can't get rid of the
virus
remember these are retroviruses so you
should know that these integrate their
genomes into your cells so you can't
clear virus yes
yes well if you can catch them before
integration occurs to a large extent
then you can prevent them from being
infected so in the early days in the
early stages when it's an acute
infection if you prevent enough Furion's
from being made with the anti
retrovirals you can catch it before it
goes into this stage yes yeah and we
will talk about that in a moment so yes
if you're suspected of being stuck you
get on to anti retrovirals right away so
we have anti retrovirals but we don't
have a vaccine yet it's a lot of work in
this area but it's a really tough
problem as you will see so you can't
block primary infection people still get
infected they get diagnosed and then
they go for antiretroviral therapy so by
that time it's too late you've already
got a pool of integrated pro viruses in
your body that you can't get rid of as a
consequence you cannot stop taking your
drugs you have to take three drugs a day
or whatever for the rest of your life if
you stop taking them the virus will once
again multiply within you and eventually
cause disease as we will see the problem
the main problem is that there are
reservoirs of cells long-lived cells
that remain within you so if the cells
turned over very quickly in in the face
of antiviral therapy you could get rid
of all the cells but there are some very
long-lived reservoirs that exist so
there have been people on
antiretrovirals for over ten years and
they still have Pro viral sequences in
certain pools and we're not even sure
what all these pools are some of them
are memory long-lived memory t-cells but
there may be other pools as well that we
don't understand and we know this
because many people stop taking their
drugs they feel great after a few years
and it's expensive so they stopped
taking them and they get AIDS again so
these experiments happen all the time
they also get drug-resistant viruses
even on triple therapy and you just
change the combination drugs are
expensive which is a No
the reason why it's problematic and all
this amounts to is that age is becoming
a third world disease you saw the
numbers in sub-saharan Africa they can't
take care of it even with antivirals
that can't afford them so the virus
spreads without control HIV too is
restricted primarily to Western Africa
it's not as widely distributed there is
homology with simian immunodeficiency
virus and we'll talk about the emergence
of these viruses later on humans who are
infected with HIV to event have
antibodies that cross-react with simian
immunodeficiency virus and this virus
causes an AIDS like disease and macaques
and so it is used as a model for trying
to understand HIV pathogenesis
it also doesn't cause disease in some
kinds of monkeys which also helps us to
try and understand the pathogenesis if
we can understand why it can't cause
disease maybe we can get clues about
intervention and I'll tell you a little
bit about that in a moment this is a
table showing the known lentiviruses
that is viruses of this same group as
HIV you can see the horse equine
infectious anemia virus and the kind of
disease it causes there are lentiviruses
of sheep goats cows cats and of course
our primate simian immunodeficiency
viruses and HIV s and these viruses are
all related as you would expect they
probably had a common ancestor and
studying them can give us clues about
where HIV came from our current thinking
is that both HIV and one-and-two came
from separate colonization events of
simian viruses and humans that is two
separate events one for HIV one one for
HIV - where the virus went from an
animal into a human and we'll talk about
what kind of animals that might be
you'll see there are involving monkeys
and in Africa where is which is where
HIV 1 & 2 emerged it involved trapping
monkeys and slaughtering them and
selling them at market and so the virus
jumped from those
animals which had virus in them and into
people at some point to do this first we
have to talk about different subtypes of
the virus the virus is HIV one anyway is
divided into what are called clades or
subtypes these are basically antigenic
groupings of the viruses there currently
ten different clades a through J and
they are based on the sequence of the
envelope and the gag genes so this is
basically a sequence alignment and there
are very distinct geographical
restrictions of these clades which is
why they're important to know about so
here's a map of the world which shows
you where the clades are they're
color-coded here you can see and you can
see that they have very distinct
restrictions for example in the areas
with the highest rates of infection you
typically which is typically sub-saharan
Africa clades a C D and E predominate
most different clades are found in
Central Africa that is the most diverse
numbers of clades elsewhere one or two
predominate so for example here in the
US and in Western Europe predominantly
clade B but it does change with time and
over time in Africa we've seen the
spread of C clade which was initially
minimal there and it has taken foothold
and spread so the the ability of people
to travel extensively makes it easy for
these clades to move around and that's
an important consideration when you
devise a vaccine because the vaccines
are likely to be clade specific and so
you may make a clade B vaccine for the
for the US but as people with other
clades move into the u.s. they're gonna
overcome that protection and so you have
to be be able to be flexible yes they
can in some cases they can correlate
with virulence and transmissibility but
we don't exactly understand that so here
are some sequence comparisons among
these lentiviruses to give you an idea
about the origins so here is a this is a
phylogenetic tree where you take the
sequence and you calculate the amount of
homology among the sequences and then
you make a tree based on what you think
might be the way these evolved from
common ancestor and this amount of
distance is 1% sequence difference on
this kind of a tree and you can see here
the primate immunodeficiency virus is on
the top and the bottom are all the
others the hoarse cat bovine goat etc
immunodeficiency viruses are down here
so here we have HIV one which is right
next to a SIV which was from a
chimpanzee so this is SIV chimpanzee and
then we have HIV 2 which is from a sooty
sooty mangabey virus so we believe that
both chimpanzee s IVs and mandrill SIV s
are very closely related to HIV one is
it's likely that HIV 1e evolved from
these viruses so again the
meat slaughtering scenario that I
suggested probably involved the
chimpanzee or a mandrill HIV 2 is
believed to have evolved from viruses
that are found in sooty mangabeys
another kind of monkey found in Africa
often kept as pets
so there's close contact between people
and these animals they can scratch you
and transmit the virus to you all right
so two separate colonization events from
some kind of a monkey into humans now
when did this happen
the oldest known sequence of HIV that we
have was from 1959 it's a serum sample
that had been stored from a Kinshasa
male and so this was taken for other
purposes in 1959 and it was stored which
was good and then in 1998 they went back
to these they were looking throughout
any any kind of clinical specimens that
they had and looking for HIV by a
variety of tests PCR for example and it
was possible to amplify the entire
genome from this sequence from this
serum sample and sequence it which is
really amazing and so that gave us a way
to clock the evolution of HIV from 1959
to the present so that was really
important to have that sequence so
that's called Zaire 59 and as far as we
can
how the sequence puts it at the
ancestral node of this D group right
here so these are all different HIV and
SIV isolates arranged according to group
so another way of isolating these
viruses is by groups which are
collections of like sequences so the D
group shown right here the ancestor was
something related to Zr 51 in of just
about two years ago another sequence was
obtained from 1960 and that's from the
Democratic Republic of the Congo this
was actually from a paraffin-embedded
formaldehyde fixed section of some
tissue from someone that was in an
archive and they got this and they were
able to pull out almost the entire HIV
sequence from this paraffin fixed sample
it's very similar to what was done with
flu if you remember I think I talked
about this the 1918 flu was
reconstructed in the same way and that
sequence is ancestral to the a group
here so in other words ancestral means
it predates all of the known sequences
that we have in that particular fork now
what's interesting is if you compare the
59 to 60 sequences you see a huge amount
of diversity already so this is already
multiplying extensively in people you
can use that sequence to calculate a
clock by which how much the virus
mutates each year and then you can back
calculate to where this probably went
from a map from a monkeys into humans
and that from that kind of analysis we
suspect that the M group up here
originated in around 1930 and probably
these viruses started in a chimpanzee
and then infected people around 1930 and
the nno groups are now thought to have a
regions from monkeys into humans so the
date 1930 isn't obviously firm but
somewhere around there is where we
believe that HIV one went from a
chimpanzee into humans the other day
someone asked me I don't know if you've
ever heard this book called the river
which suggests that clinical trials with
polio vaccine in the 1950s in Africa was
the source of the HIV and
you ever heard about that no well it's a
book written about eight years ago now
before all this sequence analysis was
done so the thesis was polio vaccines
were tested in Africa they were
propagated in chimpanzee cells of some
sort which had HIV in them and then they
were fed to people and that's what
started the outbreak so that's totally
wrong because we now know that these
viruses by the sequence analysis
originated in 1930 and the so from 1930
until 1980 what is going on it took that
many years for this virus to replicate
and spread to the extent in populations
that it became a notifiable disease and
this is a graph that illustrates what we
think is happening this is the
population of various cities in our
towns in Africa around the epicenter of
where we believe HIV emerged so this is
starting in 1880 this is the population
and these are when these individual
places were founded Kinshasa Brazzaville
yaoundé these were all places in the
area where we believe the original
trance pc's transmission occurred you
can see very very small populations and
none of these had populations greater
than a hundred thousand until well into
the 40s and 50s so it took a long time
for the virus to spread from the initial
infected individuals throughout the
population and you see very large
explosions of population there were
massive population movements there were
Wars that displaced people and then in
the 1980s all of that was enough to get
the virus and many people so it's a very
interesting story which really makes
sense in terms of population growth in
that country and then of course once it
was established in Africa could spread
elsewhere as well now there are some
interesting things we find out about
studying HIV replication in the animals
where it came from it turns out that
old-world monkeys are resistant to HIV
infection so the animals from which the
virus came are resistant to it it has
now evolved in people such that
there's no longer it being able to
infect these animals now this there is a
protein in these monkeys called trim5
alpha and that's why the the cells of
these animals are resistant to infection
this is called a restriction factor and
it's believed to protect to have
protected these animals from HIV
infection over the years our trim5
doesn't block HIV obviously otherwise we
wouldn't be talking about this right now
for some reason our trim5 has had to
stay constant maybe there are some other
pressures put on it we don't really
understand but it doesn't have the
sequence that a old world monkey trim5
alpha has and therefore we are
susceptible to infection but studying
this provides us with some ideas about
how we could interfere with HIV
infection so that's why this kind of
research is informative also if you take
cells from south african south american
owl monkeys these are also resistant to
HIV infection that's because of a
different protein it's trim5 fused to a
second protein called cyclic fill and a
yeah it's thought to be part of the
innate immune system of animals so this
this is the only known function at the
moment whether it does something else
we don't really know old-world monkeys
have a similar fusion protein that also
helps prevent HIV infection so this is
trim5 and this is how we think it works
so normally in cells that don't have
trim5 alpha or one that doesn't block
infection the retrovirus fuses with the
cell membrane the core is deposited in
the cytoplasm it undergoes reverse
transcription and eventually goes in the
nucleus so that the DNA can integrate
into that of the cell if you have trim5
present one model is that there's some
protein and there's trim5 in the cell
that's the green protein here it binds
the core and prevents it from either on
coding it may block reverse
transcription it may block transport
into the nucleus
it could target it for degradation we
don't know how this works but the idea
is that this protein by itself or maybe
with another protein somehow it blocks
the integration of the viral DNA so
trim5 alpha defines very precise steps
people are trying to sort out how this
works and maybe you could then target it
with an inhibitor of sorts alright let's
talk a little bit about transmission
which professor silverstein mentioned
before it is not a particularly
infectious virus not like measles virus
which is highly contagious HIV is not
spread by respiratory alimentary or
vector routes some of the more common
routes of transmission that we've talked
about here are two different graphs
depicting the transmission of of HIV
infection and by what mechanism here in
the US from 1981 to 2003 male to male
sexual contact which peaked around 93
and then went down now is sort of
plateaued intravenous drug use and
heterosexual contact which is on the
rise so in the u.s. you can see for many
years male to male sexual contact was
the primary mode of transmission but now
all three are very close in their
contribution to transmission if you look
at the rest of the world you have a very
different picture and that's here on the
right in the pie chart
80 to 85 percent of transmissions of
cases are transmitted heterosexually in
outside of the US and then homosexual
transmission five to ten percent
intravenous drug use five to ten percent
blood transfusions three to five percent
so contaminated blood where you don't
pick up the presence of virus and other
unknown mechanisms of transmission so
this is important HIV transmission in
most of the world is by heterosexual
transmission now how does that happen so
you would think immediately that it's
virus that is transmitted in in sexual
fluids but there's still some debate
over whether it's
virus or virus within cells or maybe
both we still I was just reading an
article this morning where they say we
still don't know the relative
contribution of free virus versus virus
within cells so this is a summary of
various studies where they looked for
the virus in either cell free fluids or
infected cells so you can see
cerebrospinal fluid ear secretions etc
feces milk plasma plasma is a large one
and that's one of the ways you
transmitted of course by blood
transfusions semen also has virus in it
vaginal cervical secretions also contain
virus but you see some of these have
very little virus like like this one
infected cells peripheral blood
mononuclear cells these are the number
of positive samples out of the number
that were tested so 89 of 92 in this
case not much in saliva semen 11 out of
28 in vaginal and cervical fluid 7 of 16
so in these areas there are also
infected cells so the point the question
is whether it's virus or virus infected
cells that is transmitting the infection
is still not established very difficult
to do these kinds of studies and that's
an important question because remember
an antibody a vaccine that induces
antibodies will prevent invite free
viruses from in fact thing but it's not
going to have an effect on a virus
infected cell so you really have to
figure that out before you can design an
effective vaccine so this is a study
done in Uganda a number of years ago
which measured the probably probability
of HIV transmission per coital ACT in
monogamous heterosexual HIV discordant
couples so that means there were
monogamous as far as they told everyone
although people never admit it when
they're not that's the problem with all
of these studies and their HIV
discordant which means one partner is
HIV positive and the other is not so you
can follow these couples and ask what's
the probability of transmission and so
you see here depending on the viral load
HIV RNA copies per milliliter of blood
there is a very different transmission
rate so very low viral loads
there's there's very low transmission
but here you can see that with 1700 to
12,500 rnas per milliliter you have a
probability for 10000 chordal acts 10 at
roughly 10 10 and 10,000 and higher
probability if you have genital ulcer
diseases makes it easier for the virus
to get into your bloodstream of course
and these probabilities go up with more
virus in the blood and I think now the
the general rule of thumb is you have
about a 1 in 200 chance of contracting
HIV by sexual mechanisms okay based on
studies such as this so it's not
terribly infectious yes yeah
no no they have to tell them you have to
always advise people to have safe sex
and when you do vaccine trials you have
to do the same thing you have to give
them you know all the right advice but
there will always be people that don't
listen and that's where you get the data
from unfortunately yeah you're obligated
on ethical grounds to do that you have
to educate yeah ok so the reason some of
the reasons why transmission is not
terribly effective in other routes is
because air drying reduces infectivity
heating so in very hot climates it's
inactivated on surfaces it's easy to get
rid of it on surfaces with bleach or
alcohol or pH extremes so not a very
Hardy virus and that goes brings us back
to structure and here again we have a
virus which isn't very resistant so it
ends up being transmitted by roots that
don't require resistance to these kinds
of extremes ok now different we learned
many weeks ago that the receptor for HIV
HIV requires 2 receptors to get into
cells one of them is cd4 the molecule on
cd4 positive T cells so that's shown
here in green so here's a cd4 positive T
cell and that's the receptor there and
there's another one but the second
receptor that written it's required it's
a chemokine receptor
that's needed for infection and remember
it's because fusion has to occur it can
be different according to the strains
there there are two different general
kinds of strains of HIV that we define
within an infected individual
we have t-cell tropic strains and these
use a alpha chemokine receptor called
cxcr4 and then there are macrophage
traffic strains that use a beta
chemokine receptor so just two different
Co receptors that define the two
different strains and I'm telling you
this because we have to talk about these
the evolution of these strains and so
you need to know what I'm talking about
alright so let's go through a typical
course of HIV so you get infected either
by free virus or virus containing cells
and the dendritic cells of course come
to the infected area and they interact
with virus which is what their job is so
you typically get infected with
macrophage atrophic strains the ones
that use that beta chemokine receptor
that I just showed you okay so not
t-cell trophic this is typically the
ones that are transmitted seem to be the
macrophage tropic strains on the surface
of dendritic cells is a molecule called
DC sign and this is what it stands for
dendritic cell specific I cam 3 grabbing
that should be a G non-integral don't
worry about the name just the fact is
that the virus attaches to it doesn't go
into the dendritic cell though it just
attaches to it and lets the dendritic
cell take it into the lymph node which
is where the cd4 positive T cells are
that it wants to infect so basically the
the dendritic cell delivers HIV to where
it goes I think this was a similar
situation for another virus that we
talked about previously so again it
doesn't the virus doesn't get into the
dendritic cell it just attaches to DC
sign on the surface the dendritic cell
having sensed an infection goes into the
lymph node with the intent of delivering
this to T cell and the virus is going to
replicate in that T cell so the virus
then goes to lymphoid tissues where it
replicates you get a lot of virus
produced then the virus spreads to other
air
other lymph nodes where it can find more
cd4 cells in which to replicate there is
an initial immune response and we'll
show some graphs of this and the immune
response is effective it down regulates
the virus load so you have initially a
peak of virus production and then we
have antibodies and and t-cells kicking
in and they limit infection but they
can't eliminate it entirely and after
about six months from the primary
infection you reach what's called the
viral set point and you have that level
of virus in your blood so you have
initial burst of virus and it reaches a
set point after about six months at
which you stay for maybe up to ten years
depending on a variety of factors so
here's a wonderful eeehm this is a
dendritic cell in the lower right and
it's got HIV particles attached to it so
it's this dendritic cells picked up the
virus particles by DC sign and this
dendritic cell is interacting with a
t-cell cd4 positive T cell which is what
the job of the dendritic cell is right
but inadvertently it's delivering virus
to the T cell these are cd4 positive T
cells and the virus is now going to
infect the T cell so it's a cruel twist
of evolution I guess that the very
mechanism intended to clear pathogens is
enabling infection by this one primary
HIV infection clinical characteristics
about fifty to ninety percent are
asymptomatic so you don't really know
that you have been infected symptoms
when they do occur five to thirty days
after exposure what kind of symptoms a
lot of nonspecific viral symptoms like
we've talked about before which are due
to cytokines being produced fever
fatigue Mel as arthralgias headache
nausea vomiting diarrhea adenopathy
swollen lymph nodes pharyngitis weight
loss leukopenia does anyone know what
leukopenia is reduced white blood cells
leukocytes I'm not gonna ask you that
but you should know these words
how about thrombocytopenia what's that
mmm low platelets so infection can cause
that as well and you all know what your
liver is median duration about two weeks
so these are primary infection symptoms
you can't tell that you have HIV okay
very nonspecific here's a very
interesting slide which shows the effect
of virus replication in the colon so
these this is a photograph of someone's
colon and within the colon are these
collections of lymphoid tissue GI
associated lymphoid tissue all these
lumps here I mean these all look like
tumors but this is NAT this is normal
bowel this is the way it's supposed to
look these are full of lymphocytes these
are basically lymph nodes on the lining
of your bowel and in an individual
infected with HIV in this case the virus
was delivered into the colon after a few
weeks all these lymph nodes are gone the
virus has destroyed all of them by
replicating in cd4 positive T cells so
the bowel looks very clean but in fact
it shouldn't be that way so here's a
graph of the course of infection we've
just talked about this initial phase so
this actually looks like an acute
infection you get infected you have a a
rise in viral RNA on the bottom here
this is HIV RNA copies per mil of plasma
so you have a peak which goes down and
by about ten weeks or so and that could
just be an acute infection on the top
are some measurements of lymphocytes so
you can see here there's an issue
decrease in the number of lymphocytes so
a normal person about a thousand cd4
positive T cells per microliter and
there's an initial drop there caused by
the virus killing them it's replicating
in them there is an increase in cd8
positive T cells these are cytotoxic T
lymphocytes whose job it is to kill
virus infected cells so there's a burst
in those we think those are important
for controlling that initial viral level
and then the virus levels go down so
these immune responses by the way this
top purple line is C D all cd8 positive
t-cells and these are virus specific cd8
positive T cells all right so then the
virus is cleared are not clear but the
levels go quite far down by about ten
weeks and then you have a long period
where there's a low amount of virus and
there are really no symptoms but during
this period the virus is killing cd4
positive T cells the cd8 s remain
constant until the very end
and then when these reach a low level
now you have development of AIDS here
the blue shaded area this is where your
immune system can no longer repel other
pathogens and you get opportunistic
infections like the Pneumocystis that
was in the first slide and canada and
many other infections as well so the
number of T cells began to decline as
those decline you can no longer fight
off infection the T cells are also going
down virus RNA levels now rise
significantly towards the end this is
ten years now eight to ten years and
then they drop again because there are
no more cd4 positive cells for the virus
to replicate in and then eventually you
get a secondary infection and you die
from that so HIV doesn't kill you but
something else kills you because you
have no immune system left it's
completely destroyed it okay
yeah yeah we're making antibodies are
going to show you what's going on there
yeah there's a there's a give-and-take
with that whole time we make antibodies
the virus changes you make new
antibodies the virus changes so you
never eliminate all the virus so if you
take antiviral drugs you can keep
yourself at a very low level without
going into this aids phase basically and
you can live like that forever I don't
know about forever but whatever a normal
lifespan is so an established infection
which is that middle part you have
active viral replication it's low levels
but the virus is still replicating there
are major reservoirs where the virus is
replicating outside of the blood one of
them is the lymph nodes where the virus
replicates eventually destroys all the
lymph nodes all the cd4 positive cells
in the lymph nodes gastrointestinal
tract lymph oh reticular tissues we shot
we saw a picture of that being destroyed
there's also reservoirs in the central
nervous system the genital tract there
are many many different kinds of viruses
they exist as a quasi species we'll talk
about what that means in evolution but
as this virus multiplies it mutates
extensively and you have huge
populations of diversify our viruses
every day you make 10 times 10 to the
ninth virion so during this middle phase
it's a huge amount of variants and then
they're destroyed in the same day huge
turnover of Furion's all right and that
gives you a lot of genetic diversity
that's what we mean by quasi species
half life of HIV and the plasma is less
than six hours so virus is made in six
hours later sometimes 30 minutes later
it's gone so very rapid turnover during
that very that intermediate phase of
disease so this just shows you some of
the various cells that are compartments
for HIV replication in the blood on the
left here we have productively infected
cd4 positive lymphocytes and these are
just half-lives of these cells so these
are very short-lived cells in the blood
this the account for about 99 percent of
the virions that are made in the blood
have a very short half-life you see six
hours here and they can go on and infect
fresh cd4 positive lymphocytes which
continue to be made until they're
outpaced by viral destruction there are
also other compartments there are lately
infected lymphocytes in various other
compartments that we mentioned which
don't make virus but they have viral
genomes in them that's what we mean by
latent ly infected and these have longer
half-lives look here eight and a half
days and 145 days for these and these
will divide and make more cells that are
lately in fact they didn't have
half-lives of 145 days so that's one of
the reasons why you can't get rid of the
virus these cells have DNA integrated in
them and the drugs don't do anything
with that and many of these can go back
into the blood and serve to produce they
can be activated and produced virus as
well so if you stop taking
antiretrovirals these lately infected
cells will move into the blood and start
producing virus that will reinfect
everything now the course of HIV
infection is variable I have told you of
a specific course but it can differ
significantly we have typical progresses
which I've told you an initial acute
infection clinical latency and then many
years later AIDS this is a reproduction
of that initial graph we also have what
are called rapid progressed errs where
you have again the primary infection and
then AIDS occurs much more rapidly than
in a typical progressor within a few
years rather than in ten years we don't
understand why this is this happens but
people would like to know because it may
give us clues about how to prevent
disease and then we have the very
interesting non progresses these
individuals are clearly infected and yet
they go on for years and years and they
never develop clinical aids and there's
a question mark here because many of
these individuals are detected in this
intermediate stage so we don't actually
know if they have had an initial acute
infection they were clearly infected at
some point but we don't know if there's
a burst of RNA here they can live
forever these are non progressives
they're also called elite controllers
because they control the infection very
well so what some of the determinants of
what's going to happen whether
it's fast or slow or intermediate or
doesn't you don't go to disease at all
whether the virus escapes from immune
responses we make antibodies and these
react with viruses but the virus
undergoes mutations in these various
proteins that escape allow the virus to
escape 10 to the ninth ten times 10 to
the ninth of virions per day among all
those very ons this probably virus is
resistant to every antibody that you
already have and if you make new ones
the viruses will change so it's it's
really a race you can't win sometimes
viruses sustained deletions one of those
accessory proteins that I showed you on
that initial slide Neff sometimes
deletions arise in the virus and those
are not pathogenic and that can explain
some of the long-term survivors the
tropism of the virus changes remember I
said infection occurs with our five
virus the macrophage tropic viruses but
in the course of an infection by the
time you have AIDS
you now have mainly x4 viruses in you
the t-cell tropic viruses and this is
often associated with increased
pathogenicity and disease progression
there are also subtypes that are that
have different potentials for
transmission in different ways and we
mentioned that earlier that some of
these subtypes are or groupings of
antigenic types can have different
pathogenicity now not just cd4 cells get
injured in aids but many other
components of your immune system as well
and I'm showing you this just to give
you a sense of that so I've told you
that the virus infects cd4 positive T
cells and and direct directly kills them
the virus is cytopathic
in those cells it destroys them and
that's one of the main reasons why AIDS
occurs but the virus also destroys many
other components look at the cd8
positive T cells remember in that graph
I showed you a decline in the number of
cd8 CTL cytotoxic T lymphocytes we think
this occurs because the precursors of
cd8 have cd4 on them they may be
affected by the virus and that will end
up killing the cd8 cells monocytes can
be killed
B cells NK cells they can all be
destroyed their functions can be
destroyed by virus infection in most
cases we don't know how this happens so
that's why we have a total immune
collapse because we lose many many of
our main components of the immune system
here's what happens in a lymph node this
is a normal lymph node at a very early
stage of infection there's a little bit
of virus though the bottom slides here
are the white dots our virus RNA being
made so initially the dendritic cells
are bringing in virions
they're transferring it to the
lymphocytes that are resident in the
lymph node and then the virus is going
to go out into the blood the lymph node
upon getting dendritic cells in it that
are reporting trouble begins to
proliferate it's called hyperplasia make
a lot of lymphocytes so that they can go
out into the blood and that's why early
on an infection you have swollen lymph
nodes and that's one of the Diagnostics
that's why the virus was originally
called lymph adenopathy virus because
one of the symptoms was swollen lymph
nodes in the intermediate stage of
infection you have more sites of viral
replication in the lymph nodes there's
what is called a follicular dendritic
Network in the lymph node where the
dendritic cells are interfacing with
lymphocytes this begins to fall apart
and then by the end or late stage
disease there are no more lymphoid cells
in these lymph nodes is all connective
tissue now here the virus has destroyed
pretty much all of the lymphocytes and
what's left there's some dendritic cells
that aren't very good at trapping virus
particles at all so the whole function
of the lymph node has really been
destroyed by virus infection and that's
that's why in part you get
immunosuppressed there are also new are
logical disorders associated with aids
besides immunosuppression about 30% of
infections have neurological disorders
of various sorts these are both direct
and indirect so by indirect for example
you can have opportunistic parasitic
infections Toxoplasma Cryptococcus that
give you neurological symptoms
you can have various lymphomas tumors
you can have an encephalitis peripheral
neuropathies muscle pain paralysis
weakness so a variety of clinical
features most of which we don't
understand the the etiology of and
that's in about 30% of infections here's
a schematic of what we think is
happening in the central nervous system
so the virus here's a virus particle
here is able to get into the CNS
remember a long time ago we talked about
the blood vein brain barrier to getting
into the CNS so these are endothelial
cells one ideas that the virus can cross
and athelia cells in the CNS the virus
can infect astrocytes
that can infect oligodendrocytes but it
does not infect and it can also infect
microglia but it cannot infect neurons
HIV doesn't infect neurons yet it does
produce neurological symptoms so the
idea is that all these infected cells
are producing a variety of cytokines and
perhaps viral proteins that give the
neuronal toxicity okay so this is just
an example of a macrophage infected
which is a microglia in the CNS if it's
infected with HIV it produces all of
these chemokines and cytokines and other
metabolites and what these have been
shown to have effects in the CNS so for
example Quin Olynyk acid produced by
macrophages is associated with CNS
disease and HIV infected children and
cytokines these cytokines tgf-beta il-6
TNF alpha are associated with other CNS
signs so we think that not a direct
virus infection of neurons but rather
all the chemicals that are produced in
response caused a lot of the CNS
symptoms you can also have cancer
associated with HIV infections have an
increased incidence of malignancy 40% of
infected individuals develop cancers one
reason is because you don't have a
functioning immune system anymore and
that's very important for surveillance
and
hearing tumors before they can get
started you don't have a good immune
surveillance another key which we'll
talk about next time when we talk about
transformation and oncogenesis making a
lot of cytokines you have huge levels of
virus all the time so your Sentinel
cells are always making cytokines and
what is one of the things that cytokines
do is to stimulate cell division and
when cells divide uncontrollably that is
a recipe for cancer because the more
cells divide the more mutations
accumulate and eventually this the cell
will become tumorigenic and also other
viruses play into this as well so
uncontrolled replication coupled with
infection by other viruses besides HIV
also leads to tumor formation so one
example is Kaposi sarcoma a tumor of
this of the connective tissue which is
shown here originally described in 1872
before aids found mostly in elderly
Mediterranean men but occurs in 20% of
HIV infected homosexual men and 2% of
HIV infected women and transfusion
recipients so the incidence markedly
higher once HIV is present these develop
they require infection with a second
virus human herpes virus 8 or Kaposi
sarcoma virus and in fact these
Mediterranean men that had Kaposi
sarcoma before AIDS era also had hhv-8
so hhv-8 will cause Kaposi sarcoma but
people with AIDS are immunosuppressed so
they're more likely to be infected with
both viruses so that's one kind of tumor
that is associated with AIDS b-cell
lymphomas are another type higher
prevalence in AIDS patients than the
general population these often result in
tumors and lymph nodes in test and CNS
and liver and we think that as the lymph
nodes are destroyed remember I showed
you that progression of destruction of a
lymph node one of the consequences is
that
normal pathways to apoptosis which
regulate lymphocyte development in a
lymph node are destroyed
and so you get uncontrolled replication
and development of b-cell tumors so
these are often associated again with
infection with either hhv-8 or
epstein-barr virus and this is an
example of what I've told you we have
HIV infection of macrophages and cd4
positive T cells the cytokines that are
produced stimulate the proliferation of
B cells endothelial cells or epithelial
cells and we talked about how infection
with hhv-8 will then lead to Kaposi
sarcoma so the combination of rapidly
dividing cells and infection with hhv-8
Kaposi sarcoma if these are b-cells
rapid multiplication followed by EBV or
hhv a gives you a lymphoma the tumor of
b-cells and we didn't mention this but
even in epithelial cells cervical
epithelial cells the same situation
rapid development rapid division human
papillomavirus infection carcinoma so
let's talk a little bit about an HIV
vaccine and this slide shows you one of
the problems that we have which we've
already discussed if you have this early
acute phase of HIV infection where you
have a lot of virus which is eventually
cleared its cleared because of an immune
response you have a very nice antiviral
immunity and it's well it's not cleared
the levels are reduced but then you have
persistence so the one one question is
how does the virus persist despite
having good antibodies against it and
how does it eventually outstrip the
immune control and some of the questions
for which we don't really have answers
yet and for which we do need answers
before we can make a vaccine do you need
antibodies for protection and recovery
do these have to be neutralizing
antibodies there's a lot of discussion
now maybe just they don't have to
neutralize in fact if 'ti maybe they
could just bind to the virus and let it
be taken up by other cell types do you
need me coastal immunity to prevent
infection or is an immunity in the blood
enough and do you need T cells we're not
even sure about that so here's an
example
what HIV does with respect to the
antibody response so you get infected
with a purple HIV here and it you make
antibodies against it you see the purple
antibodies here but by the time these
antibodies are produced the virus has
changed to an orange virus so it's
mutated and these purple Ana the
antibodies no longer bind to the virus
so your body detects this orange virus
and starts to make orange antibodies but
by the time you do that you now have
blue HIV particles and this is what goes
on in that intervening period between
the acute infection and AIDS the virus
is always out stripping the antibodies
it's sort of like satchel page in a way
right and here is a graph of an
experiment which demonstrates this
specifically so we have a patient
infected with with HIV and we take serum
at the time a month zero 6 and 12 and
then we react that serie with month 0
virus from that same patient in month 12
virus okay so month 0 virus by 6 months
as of you make a very nice immune
response against it actually you have a
good immune response even at month 0 it
gets stronger and then it stays the same
by 6 and 12 months so 0 virus can be
neutralized 6 and 12 months out but the
problem is that at 12 months there is
another virus which is not neutralized
by the month 0 or month 6 and barely by
the month 12 plasma so this is a
practical showing of how the virus is
changing over time so that's one of the
problems the virus changes so quickly
that you can't neutralize it now what
would be the effect if at day 0 you had
neutralizing antibodies we don't know
because we don't have a vaccine that's
been able to do that yet and so we're
not even sure if you block all infection
whether it would the virus would still
evolve to overcome it yeah
Yeah right right
No
so the question is does this virus
change more rapidly than any other RNA
virus so the error rate is the same the
problem here is that every day you make
ten to the ten ten times ten to the
ninth
particles so you have a huge
productivity and turnover so if you make
one mistake for ten thousand bases
that's a huge number of mistakes so
every milliliter of blood has uncounted
numbers of mutations so it's a
particular kind of disease here that
lends it to this kind of escape this is
just another way of looking at the same
data these are again HIV escape these
are viruses taken at 0 3 6 etc all the
way out to twenty five months so these
are from HIV infected patients and these
are plasma taken at different times and
then you try and neutralize the virus
with the different plasma so every
plasma is incubated with every virus
sample to make this matrix and then you
mix the vibe the plasma with the virus
then you ask is the virus still
infectious that's a neutralization assay
so you can see the virus at zero months
is nicely neutralized by all of the Sira
from them about day three years from
about month three or so all the way out
to 25 months but the virus at 25 months
you can see is poorly neutralized by the
whole panel because this is arisen at
the point where this sample has been
taken and it's going to take another
month or so to make antibodies by which
time you'll have a month you know 26
virus so yes okay sorry so the number is
the inverse of the dilution where you
get 50% neutralization it's just oh it's
just a standardized way of calculating a
neutralization titer so here 50%
neutralization was at a dilution of one
to 219 there's also evidence that cd8
positive cells the so-called C tiel's
are important for control of HIV as the
virus goes
down that's a period when you have an
early CTL response I showed a picture of
that if you do an infection of macaques
with its SIV
you can show that if you take away their
cd8 cells what you can do experimentally
they have a worse infection so the CDL
eighths are definitely contributing to
protection you also get selection of
viral escaped mutants so CT ELLs
recognize specific viral epitopes the
virus can change those sequences as well
just like antibodies recognize an
epitope and those viral epitopes can
change the same thing can happen with
CTL epitopes they can change as well so
we see that during the course of an HIV
infection you get CTL epitope changes so
that suggests that they're important now
here's a little bit more information on
CTLs and elite controller so elite
controllers fall into very specific
human leukocyte antigen classes B 57 or
B 27 so you know the class the class 2
MHC molecules on your cell surface
define how or participate in
presentation of antigen to t-cells and
it there are many different kinds of
major histocompatibility molecules in
the population that's so it's highly
polymorphic and the more variation you
have the more foreign antigens you're
able to recognize it turns out that
these individuals with either a B 57 or
B 27 you can have your HLA typed if your
B 57 or B 27 you have a high likelihood
of being an elite controller that is
having infection but never getting AIDS
and what we think is that these
individuals can accommodate even highly
mutated epitopes in the in the MHC
molecule so remember MHC presents a
little viral peptide to a t-cell the T
cell recognizes it as foreign and lysis
that cell if the epitope if the viral
epitope mutates it won't be recognized
by the MHC but apparently these elite
controllers have a MHC that can
recognize a wide range of peptides in
all has to do with the way the T cells
are educated in the
we don't have time to go into it but
it's a very interesting idea that very
early in development your thymus samples
all kinds of peptides and decides which
ones are going to be foreign and which
ones are going to be yourself so these
these kinds of HLA types apparently are
very good at accommodating a wide range
of viral epitopes so here's an
experiment where we take CTLs away from
an animal this is a macaque infected
with HIV so in a normal situation you in
fact they have bursts of virus and then
the CTLs peak and clear the virus at the
same time but if you take away the CTL
which you can do experimentally you get
much more virus replication so again
this is just suggesting that CTL is in
addition to antibody are likely to be
important for protection so back to
these elite HIV controllers these are
individuals that as I said can last for
a number of years one in 300 infected
people are likely to be elite
controllers and they're associated with
favorable HLA types which i've already
told you not via there's no change in
viruses that seem to be associated with
this phenotype they have virus their
entire life but they never progress to
age and if you want to read a listen to
this we talked about this on my podcast
a number of months ago where the idea is
that the education of these t-cells in
the in the thymus is of these
individuals are particularly different
so can you cure HIV infection you can
limit viral replication with antiviral
therapy but as I said there are
persistent reservoirs are of infection
there are long-lived memory T cells
macrophages even stem cells in your bone
marrow are elsewhere that have Pro viral
DNA in them and that's going to be very
difficult to eradicate so I think
prevention of infection is really going
to be the key here unless we can figure
out how to get pro viruses out of these
cells we're going to have to focus on a
prevention of infection and those
individuals were already infected are
going to have to stay on antivirals for
their
to our lives
you